sollte schauen wir aber erstmal auf
kreml trainer wladimir putin und seine
barbaren regierung die versuchen nämlich
weiterhin die russen bevölkerung im
unklaren über ihre völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine zuletzt
aber mit der propaganda ist das so eine
sache das kann auch nach hinten losgehen
die russische propaganda maschinerie
läuft auf hochtouren klingt erstmal nach
profis doch anscheinend sind im land der
fake news ziemliche dilettanten am werk
wie hier die neueste meisterleistung
putin teams und ex präsident dimitri
medwedew besucht vor kurzem die
russischen truppen in der region
orenburg dabei soll er laut der
russischen nachrichtenagentur tass auch
truppenübungen beobachtet haben dazu
verbreiteten die kreml medien dieses
foto von mit video der haken der
vize-chef des sicherheitsrates konnte
gar nicht sehen die klappen seines
fernglases versperrten die sicht bild
zeigt ihnen die top 5 peinlichsten
propaganda fez der russen seit
kriegsbeginn platz fünf sim-karten fail
im april sorgte dieses foto für
ordentlich lacher im netz hier wurde
laut tyrann geheimdienst fsb ein neonazi
festgenommen gefunden wurden unter
anderem sechs sprengsätze acht
molotow-cocktails sechs pistole eine
granate mehr als 1000 patronen drogen
und gefälschte ukrainische besser doch
eines ist ziemlich auffällig auf den gut
präparierten propaganda fotos zwischen
hakenkreuz t shirt und neonazi literatur
lag fein drapiert drei
erweiterungspakete des beliebten
computerspiel sims 3
vermutlich wurde von einem
geheimdienstler die einkaufsliste falsch
verstanden statt drei sim-karten auf
russisch triesen wurden drei
computerspiele gekauft platz vier
peinliche propaganda show im mai fuhr
der kreml mächtig auf mit einer mega
propaganda schutz um 8 jährigen jubiläum
der annexion der krim im moskauer
olympiastadion luschniki hielt kreml
diktator putin eine rede an die nation
doch etwas lief schief die putin rede
wurde im tv live übertragen als mitten
im satz die propaganda show ein jähes
ende fand aus dem kreml hieß es etwa
eine halbe stunde nach der unterbrechung
es habe einen serverfehler gegeben
ziemlich schnell für die propaganda
delhi tanten
platz drei bonnie und clyde im russen tv
zum jahrestag des sieges der sowjetunion
über nazi deutschland am 9 mai strahlte
der russische sender channel one sein
traditionelles konzert aus aber ein foto
zog die ganze zeremonie ins lächerliche
im hintergrund der bühne wurden alte
schwarz weiß bilder lächelnder
russischer paare von 1945 gezeigt
plötzlich jedoch ein foto des
berühmtesten verbrecher persiens der
amerikanischen geschichte bonnie und
clyde
platz zwei flugzeugträger der jüngste
patzer instrument in westsibirien wurden
plakate aufgehängt um den tag der
russischen marine zu feiern im zentrum
eines der plakate zu sehen ein
flugzeugträger umrankt von russischen
marine flaggen die überschrift alles
gute zum tag der marine blöd nur dass
das auf den plakaten abgebildete
kriegsschiff gar nicht von der
russischen marine ist die dort
abgebildete uss age double you busch ist
ein flugzeugträger der united states
navy und gehört somit den amerikanern
nicht den russen
platz eins moskwa gleicher tag andere
panne diesmal von einer russischen
zeitung in baschkortostan gratulierte
die regionalzeitung ihren lesern zum tag
der russischen marine unveröffentlichte
dazu auf seiner website ein foto des
kreuzers moskwa über dem die weiß-blaue
marine flagge wehte die überschrift
heute ist der tag der russischen marine
peinlich aber die moskwa liegt auf dem
meeresgrund putins flaggschiff übrigens
das größte russische kriegsschiff seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg wurde von der
ukraine am 14 april versenkt das
bestätigte an jenem abend auch das
verteidigungsministerium in moskau
damals war die zerstörung der moskwa
eine peinliche klatsche für putin in
seinem blutigen überfall auf die ukraine
naja das dürfte dem kreml so gar nicht
gefallen da müssen wir natürlich noch
mal drüber sprechen mit einem der sich
auskennt chefreporter peter tiede peter
also diese russische propaganda maschine
die gilt auch eigentlich als wahnsinnig
mächtig als erfahren wie kann es sein
dass man tatsächlich solche fenster
ständig passieren dass am ende des tages
komplett egal ist wenn die von morgens
bis abends liebst dann kann es auch mal
ein falsches bild zeigen und das ist dem
tatsächlich völlig egal die hauptsache
ist dass ist bei 80 prozent der leute
über 90 prozent der leute fängt das ist
dann fehlt sind dass es ein fake sind
das feld die wenigsten robusten auf das
erfahren dann auch die wenigsten großen
hauptsache die bilder stunden das würde
gerade fragen jetzt erfährt dass keiner
das dass anna maria ich meine bonnie and
clyde soria andere
der großen parade bonnie und clyde ist
muss doch irgendwas muss sich darum es
gibt es geht dann wie dann viral und es
gilt dann auch wieder als sympathisch
dass wir die projekte angeht so mächtige
propagandamaschine doch nicht allmächtig
ist dann sagt man guckt mal so schlimm
kann's ja gar nicht sein und kann ja
nicht alles konnte kann ich alles
kontrolliert sein es zeigt aber auch
dass es vielen menschen auch die in den
apparat arbeiten die der propaganda
arbeit schlicht und ergreifend total
egal ist was sie da wirklich zeigen also
nehmen wir mal den flugzeugträger jetzt
kannst du mit einem russischen
flugzeugträger auch echt nicht angeben
die admiral kusnezow oft das ist der
einzige russische flugzeugträger man
besitzt tatsächlich nur ein der ist noch
zu sowjetzeiten gebaut waren auf einer
werft ausgerechnet in der heutigen
ukraine und das ding kannst du nicht
vorzeigen wenn der durch die welt dieser
fährt kennen wir die bilder da ist ein
riesengroßer rußwolke über dem meer weil
diese wenn dieser uralte uralte
flugzeugträger ersten ständig kaputt ist
eine alte maschine hat und drittens
wirklich nichts taugt da fallen auch die
flugzeuge darunter dann nimmt man besser
wenn man schon einen zeigen will den
amerikanischen flugzeugträger die haben
wenigsten vernünftige dabei ausgerechnet
das müsste doch dann eigentlich
auffallen wenn man nur ein hat und der
so unterschiedliche aussieht und dann
nimmt man ausgerechnet so ein top stück
der amerikaner dann müsste man doch auch
mit rechnen dass die amis irgendwie
drauf reagieren oder ja aber wenn die
amis reagieren heißt das ja nicht dass
die nachricht auch in tiefen russland
ankommt und bei der ba muss draußen auf
dem land ankommt da kommst nicht an die
kugel ins internet die ist nicht bei
twitter facebook ist ohnehin gesperrt
facebook und twitter auch und wie gesagt
die hauptsache ist die meisten leute
denken dass man toll ist und die leute
fahren ja auch im rostigen kaputten lada
durch über alte kaputte straßen durch
kaputte steht oder dörfer und nach
hinten drauf den aufkleber wir haben den
zweiten weltkrieg gewonnen nach berlin
die hauptsache ist die bilder stimmen
die propaganda überschriften stimmen wie
es im land aussieht was da gezeigt wird
egal aktueller fall ja auch die krim
sagte russland ja das sei ein brand in
einem munitionslager ausgebrochen es
gibt jetzt aktuelle bilder die zeigen
vorher nachher da ist also ein
luftwaffenstützpunkt bombardiert worden
mutmaßlich eben von ukrainischer seite
auf enstar keine offizielle bestätigung
gibt da sieht man aber dramatische
schäden tatsächlich sind sieben jets
kampfjets die dort stationiert waren
sind mit einem schlag kaputt ja und die
kampfjets die kann man zur not noch
ersetzen aber das was man links und
rechts gilt gesehen hat wie nämlich
wirklich panikartig die leute die
strände auf der krim verlassen haben und
dann auch die krim verlassen haben es
gibt bilder von der krim brücke da
fahren die touristen nur in eine einzige
richtung die gegenrichtung auf die krim
die ist leer und auf der anderen seite
herrscht stau das in das vertrauen
verloren gegangen da haben die russen
zum ersten mal gespürt buch der krieg
findet jedoch bei uns statt uns in die
einführung zeichen weil die krim ist
ukrainische staatsgebiet es ist ein
großes bild besetzt aber dann macht man
lustig ferienzeit 2014 ich war ein paar
mal da hat mir das auch angeguckt weil
auch baden und da macht man
patriotischen urlaub und jetzt mitten in
den patriotischen urlaub kleinen die
ukraine mutmaßlich mit im angriff rein
und dass die ukraine regelmäßig schon
mal auch russisches staatsgebiet nicht
nur jetzt die krim die er besetzte grimm
angegriffen haben habe ich selber mal
erlebt also schon nach zwei wochen krieg
ist ein militärflughafen auf der
russischen seite angegriffen und von der
ukrainischen drohne also zeit dass in
die russen merken das ist sie
tatsächlich krieg haben danke für deine
einschätzung
[Musik]